uh a lot of news has broken and I guess
we gotta start off with the main one
um Jim Ryan this is King's topic uh yeah
new management structure of Sony
interactive entertainment Jim Ryan to
retire next spring and haroki to Toki to
assume uh interim CEO role while keeping
his current role as Sony group so um
yeah it was announced he said that
effective um
immediately that uh see about Factory
but uh CIO president and CEO Jim Ryan
has made the decision to retire in March
of 2024 after almost 30 years with the
PlayStation business to support variety
of this transition as we talked about on
CFO and CEO herokis Toki will sue the
role of chairman of Sie effective
October 2023 and then um he will be
invited into a CEO
why you got to do the duplicate lab
anyway so um yeah Jim Ryan was there
since uh like in 94 and then um since
then he's held number of senior
positions at the company including
president of s-i-e-e head of global
sales and marketing at siee Deputy
president of Siege January 2018 before
appointed Sie president and CEO and then
yes but I said wow oh okay
uh Yoshida has had a comment it's a Jim
Ryan was an inspirational leader
throughout this entire period with us
but never more so in overseeing the
launch of PlayStation 5 in the midst of
the global covid pandemic so he goes on
to again to continue Rave and talk about
how you know he's helped the business
Jim Ryan has made his statement
officially after 30 years I've made the
decision to retire from Sie in March of
2024. I've relished the opportunity to
have a job I love in a very special
company working with great people and
incredible Partners but I found it
increasingly difficult to reconcile
living in Europe and working in North
America I will leave having been
privileged to work on products that
touch millions of lives across the world
PlayStation will always be a part of my
life and I feel more optimistic than
ever about the future of s-i-e I want to
thank Yoshida sound for placing so much
trust in me and being an incredible
supportive sensitive and supportive
as the most
um when did he take over it said 2019 I
think yes I think Deputy president of
Sie since January 2018 before being
point but yeah maybe 2019 maybe right
there yeah but um
he's been with Sony but as far as talk
about the head yeah yeah that I'm trying
to get the clarity there because it
doesn't say specifically just said that
he Deputy president since 2018. so it
could be between that 2018 2019. so so
to be clear too he didn't he didn't
specifically replace Sean Laden because
they were different they're different
positions so technically like John
Legend's replacement was Herman Holst
right and and not necessarily like Jim
is like the boss of everything right
like Jackson like like a like Jack like
a Jackie t or um an Andrew house or
something like that yeah so you know yes
crazy I was um
looking he he wasn't there that long
like in that position like three four
years yeah so mad short so kick this is
your topic obviously of course it's
King's top the realm wants to hear from
you I'm supposed to let you talk I'm
gonna mute my mic so yeah man you got to
beat your mind I want you in on this I
told you dudes Jim wouldn't make it past
the next fiscal period dude said King he
has some record sales he has a game of
the year candidate coming out he has
game of the years multiple years there
has been uh nominated your man has the
service he Consolidated he's making
money hand over fists I said I don't
care what you saying he's out by next
fiscal period you're a crackpot your man
is gone my name is
yo
y'all so successful your stop reporting
numbers
you're so successful you didn't pay the
ransom to get back to customers data
you talk about the leakings
they say yo we got your customers data
they said we don't care about the
customer do what you got to do
we don't negotiate with terrorists
that's how much they care about the fan
base they care about you so much before
Jim left he said I'm gonna raise the
price of the surface
he said and guess what he killed the
Slate of all the games remember y'all
sitting there talking about we got games
coming out this day in the third y'all
know what's coming out now yeah
absolutely no I don't know what you do
know is y'all got 10 games of services
and he just raised the price on the
services
he said before I leave this is how much
I love y'all yo
that is kind of funny
he left and was like here's my parting
gifts
he went out and snitched put a light on
top of SUNY Stoney can't do their
underhanded deals no more y'all can't do
the stuff that y'all was doing with
square that's why square games is in it
on Xbox because the FTC got the
contracts they said yo young man went
over there imagine you going to the
teacher snitching on somebody and he
locked you up
[Laughter]
how Jim is going to tell on Xbox and he
gets kid
he like Phil is doing Mad stuff why I
gotta go so so this is a direct result
of um this is a direct result of the ABK
deal oh okay uh Sony you could have took
the deal and got more games you just got
Call of Duty for 10 years you got the
same contract everybody else got but
you're supposed to be Sony Elite no more
ABK games for you all you negotiated was
successfully was Call of Duty you lost
the deal is gonna go through and they're
gonna have ABK now the money on Call of
Duty gotta go to Xbox the the funny part
too is they they were offering the full
ride right they it's it's like it's like
being offered like a full ride
scholarship to a a school and try to
negotiate higher than that and they end
up not getting they end up getting like
okay you get one class you get one class
you gotta pay for the rest you got an
EBT card and a bus pass
he said that is over that boat concealed
yo
you are that was the officially the
worst negotiation tactic like you sold
all the stuff that came out none of the
information would have came out none of
these uh back door stuff would have came
out none of that redacted stuff would
have came out and I keep on hearing the
PlayStation fan base saying Jim is
leaving on a high note
bro you literally don't know what's
going on for the next four years well
that's one let me let you talk you had
two piss-paul shows the one game that
you launched this year was an exclusive
was a dudge y'all talking about red four
y'all got to get together the services
they told you is going up by 40 bucks
not one dollar
where's this number come from who the
hell just said 40 bucks like somebody
said 40 bucks and they thought that it
was worth it the service ain't even
worth what they asking now and this dude
stepped out and said 40 bucks he did a
passion project was called VR right
that didn't sell he done another passion
project right before he leaves he put
your right direction
too he did all the passion projects all
the stuff he wanted to do remember we
were sitting there saying why is this
stuff coming out who is it selling to he
did Passion projects to sink you guys
because he knew he was gonna lose the
ABK deal he said you know what I'ma sink
this whole [__] and see it's your Donnie
he's your Donnie and let me tell you
this y'all don't got enough money to
survive this oh my God
here we go and it's always ps6
let me hear this and I told you he was
leaving right y'all laughed true the
joke's on you now no no you're right now
no no not sure not you I'm talking about
them now
I'm telling you Bungie is going to leave
oh this is the new one
she's going to leave because all the
work is being thrown on Bungie Destiny
has been absolute garbage since Sony has
acquired them I cannot dispute the stuff
that has been going on with bungee you
know why it's garbage because Bungie is
overworked and underpaid um
everything else worrying about Marathon
worrying about 10 games and services
they're going to leave you know how she
gets when she don't like doing extra
work she's out of there and she has the
prenup already signed she good money and
everybody gonna get paid she's gonna go
away Coke said they contract is ill and
they she was surprised that Sony agreed
to a level of contract Freedom that um
Bungie has you know agreed to but yeah
no no continue continue no I mean this I
just I just want to say
was yo Donny
and the reason why I believe y'all can't
recover from this
Microsoft is building Steam
you don't have enough time to play
catch-up
a god of war is not going to work it
ain't gonna work y'all can try you could
be y'all can have him in Egypt
and Horace
I I hate to interrupt because I'm not
supposed to but I just had to ask a
quick question so you're saying the
reason why the um the God of War stuff
is not going to work because like like
your old analogy when you had remember
when you had all the games the the
bangers and you know God of War the
Spider-Man and you said that Jim said
all of this doesn't equal to this one
game because of the revenue from that so
you saying now because of the Call of
Duty situation is that they're in a bad
spot
just want to say Gonna Save them it's a
Cascade of things you raise the price on
your service so you're gonna make people
leave the service right because you you
just gave them an ultimatum get down to
lay down right you already know y'all
get TCL television y'all cheat
so y'all gonna lay down y'all be like
nope I'm not about this I'm out of here
I'm not gonna pay for your service your
original PlayStation dudes was bulking
at the fact that they did have to pay
for someone when you gotta trick them
that time remember you'll never play for
online
um that would be 39.
okay so okay
the Microsoft having this uh head start
with Services right Microsoft having
Head Start and multiplayer Microsoft
taking your most uh coveted Advantage
which was Call of Duty and the marketing
rights that's going to be removed from
you guys so that's going to be on Xbox
you can't no longer run out there and be
like yo all you do is dumb um Call of
Duty's only over here over yeah the
market 500 million that you was paying
the um uh Activision that's going to
Microsoft that's funding your demise
you're absolutely right with that I
won't push back my question to you is
but what about Jim's the success as far
as the console sales as far as
dominating Sony's most greatest era as
far as sales consoles right now
oh my God the console soldiers you know
why I can say the console sold the
scalpers the ratio to games out there to
consoles don't match okay
they don't match like not even one
percent of your your fan base purchase
game is weird it don't match it don't
match with the online y'all got a
hundred and twenty something five
million online dudes why are none of
them buying anything like why does Jim
have to leave now in a cloak of secrecy
like I'm out of here you know it's me
traveling back and forth has been too
much you caused the problem like if you
never said what you said you know what
you did when you went to Brazil you
tried to speak in Spanish it didn't work
out we found out what you did now now
you're upset because it didn't go your
way they don't speak Spanish
so but the problem is you started all of
this
stuff now it didn't go your way okay
okay you said we have nothing to compete
we call it Duty um
that's after you brought budgie like
yeah that's a fact about like a week
later that's a fact so nothing you guys
can compete with it so that means you're
God of War remember what I told y'all
that means you're Horizon that means
you're Spider-Man you can't compete with
Call of Duty he did say that so now that
Call of Duty is here what did he say I
cannot compete I'm out of here
the ABK failure to get the deal blocked
that is that part is is that was the
demise so so this is a rules there's
retirement is a rules to you that's
right no no it's not a rules all right
so what is it really retired he really
looked at it and was like oh hell no I'm
not going back in there oh I remember
the last time you saw him
okay that was the last time you saw him
right so when you when we saw the place
stay to play you thought he was going to
come out they send somebody else out and
then they did what was that game Happy
Feet baby steps baby steps you should
have known from baby steps it was a wrap
for you dudes it is absolutely done and
I'm having the time of my life because I
told you it was gonna happen and y'all
looked at me and said King he ain't
going nowhere he's the most successful
that we had true no what he did was he
crapped on Japan took those people out
of there took him over to the EU and he
made that's his home base the eu's
fighting like hell for him right now to
get their ABK there because they know
once it's over there's no PlayStation 6.
they want to say their PlayStation [__]
I'm down with y'all but um no it's not
gonna happen but listen Jim thank you
thank you so much for all the damage you
did so so so in your eye just sort of
clear yes this is a Don metric situation
oh God that so despite the console sales
despite the success of this being one of
the best PlayStation errors for him you
your thought process is that he's done
long-term damage that they're not going
to be able to recover from he told them
he doesn't care about any other games
except for Blockbuster the AAA types of
fact he said that Sean Laden Phil
Dominus Maximus Aurelius Spencer and
everybody in the industry says AAA
titles are not sustainable the prices of
these games have gone up astronomically
and you do not get a return on
investment especially when Sony games
are one and done there's no multiplayer
component to these games so you spend x
amount of dollars on Horizon you want
money back right it don't matter if it
sells uh uh a thousand copies when it's
ten dollars they want to sell at Peak
price remember he raised the price on
y'all the industry had to follow right
he did raise he started they started the
seventy dollar movies all right but what
about what about the remixing and the
remaking and then moving with the movies
and then the PC getting the money on the
back end let me let me let me do this
let me let me say this let's go to every
fan fan person of a PlayStation because
you're not a boy you're a person you
know a fan person uh console okay
does Sony look the same
they feel I really want you to take a
deep reflection on that question I know
y'all throw out numbers and stuff y'all
all like to throw out numbers until one
day it really fell a blocked the bus it
was at the top of the Heap until one day
y'all went outside and it's gone y'all
don't even use VCRs no more but I want
y'all to just really think of this
has PlayStation look like PlayStation
this year
look at it from the two whack game shows
those shows are horrible but smoking
came out y'all was beating your chest on
that Final Fantasy came out it was a
good game but it wasn't a good Final
Fantasy game now you got the last hope
the Last Hope is Spider-Man and I told
y'all before it's DLC I'm gonna call it
Game of the Year for me but it's still
the same thing y'all have what what four
Spider-Man games in five years
Morales in this one you get to play
Spider-Man and this one you get to play
both
and let's remix what we gave you a remix
in every vehicle they Puff Daddy in it
this
yo I'm so sick and tired of you guys
pumping out your chest acting like
something is really happening when the
world is passing you by you you outside
of your house screaming dial up this is
what you're doing you yelling down up
and dudes on DSL and Wi-Fi you you out
there on that you're on a rotary phone
and everybody got an iPhone
last but he you have to give him credit
for at least you yourself where he was
pushing the PC ports they're pushing the
live service in the mobile you was like
yo Jim is is you want it you was winning
with that I want him to do that yeah
that's the closest you that's get over
to the PC yeah need this Hardware stuff
alone you're not good at that let's
leave that alone let's put that over
there right let's go back to being a
developer let's do this how about this
how about this how about you go make
games since you make great single first
person story driven games
[Music]
he already planned his retirement
he's really not in the building like
he's sent out a tweet
one thing I will say is that it's weird
that he's leaving and like there's no
thought process at all about a successor
like it does feel like and let's get to
it if you look at if you look at like
when
because obviously the the latter
situation is different than when it came
to you know Sean and you know Jack
Trenton and stuff but to me it feels
like
why announce it this early
why if he's leaving a marsh why it would
make more sense to hold on to that
information
until you get to March or closer to that
date when you have a successor
but to me
it's either Jim wants out now
or they want Jim out now oh so you think
it's nefarious you think that I I don't
know like all I know is
it's ironically and it might be a
coincidence that he's leaving right
after the ABK deal would be finalized at
that point you implying because of his
lack of success of getting the ABK deal
blocked that this led I don't attention
to his demise if he is being pushed out
I don't think it's one or two things
like I think it's a variety of things
you know we've seen with days gone days
gone so well you deserved a sequel from
cells why didn't PlayStation give that
one oh yeah because they care more about
their reputation than they care about
cells to a point
um
so
when you look at this like look Jim Ryan
has made them a lot of money but we've
seen with games they care more about
their reputation if not more on the same
terms as they care about money and what
is Jim Ryan done since he's took over he
is had to shut Studios down he's had a
defunct Studios because it didn't work
out well look what just happened with
the Knights of the Old Republic we don't
even know if that game's still Greenland
it's gone he's converted their the what
made the studios what made PlayStation's
identity identity we don't know if any
of those or games are coming out they're
all games as a service now
he he made us wait for two years for a
showcase and gave us nothing for it that
showcase was not not good I'll give you
that clearly there there's some kind of
issue when it comes to developing
because where are their games oh my God
PlayStation has no problem showing you
something that comes out six years from
now now but you know what that's a
different PlayStation
yeah King that was Sean Layton's
PlayStation
you mean young man had somebody spayed
hand and they told him don't mess up the
game and they left and came back and he
lost the game he had a winning Spade
hand and threw in his hand and then and
then you got to look at it from this
perspective too
obviously obviously this isn't Sean
Layton's fault but in his Reign he's
allowed Microsoft to buy Bethesda he's
allowed Microsoft to buy ABK he's
allowed Microsoft to take multiple key
components uh Studios out of of
commission look is that Sean Lane's
fault uh is that uh Jim Ryan's phone no
but do you not think the executives care
no when we when you took over the
landscape was different not why we
losing Call of Duty next year so the
shareholders is so basically just I just
want to be clear he you know you feel
either him or the shareholders it was a
mission to stop the ABK because when the
news came out
the real Jim Wright dude said oh we
ain't worried about that right we we got
Bungie we he was popping off so then so
now that the stuff came out with Lulu
and then he was like saying like we
don't care what we're going to do we're
gonna block this deal so you who do you
think do you think it was his mission to
block it he did oh God he didn't do it
or the shell like what because I see you
kind of going here you're hinting about
this APK I feel I think it could have
either way but I am leaning more towards
Jim Ryan
you know they've they're losing faith in
Jim Ryan uh that's what I feel because
yeah it's like I said it's it's not a
coincidence right after this event uh
with with the ABK now he's talking about
leaving you know and let's be real here
a lot of his Heights
was approved in greenlit by Sean Layton
Jim was working off the coattails of old
oh Sean
all right so when the cool went down uh
Jim was the ring lady yourself yes Jim
was railing and you know it's not that
he didn't make the money he made them a
lot of money he made him about a lot of
money at the end of the day it's like we
said with the game portion if that's how
they feel about the games but he didn't
take out the termites if that's how they
feel about the games that's how they got
to feel about their overall company and
I'm sure you make me x amount of money
but what else are you seeing poor
PlayStation people like Jack blue Johnny
Persona uh you know uh Jabari they're
saying more negative stuff about
PlayStation the good these days they're
going on they're saying I don't agree
with this decision I don't agree with
that decision and they still love the
brand and they're willing to to sit by
it but you're seeing more of this happen
and you know I've seen it when God of
War Ragnarok came out I saw a lot of
tweets like you know I love this game
it's a good game but I'm kind of getting
drawn out when it comes to this style
gameplay because it's like DLC you
saying no
okay well yes yes when we call Jim over
to the office we said Jim uh I need you
to have a seat
now you know we've been noticing the
numbers are good but something don't
look right in the light Jim
something to look great in your life now
um
they come to my attention that you were
the one that started all this mess now
we had a good deal over there with
Microsoft and you took it upon yourself
to say that no you wanted to kill the
Dell in its entirety now we told you sir
if the deal doesn't get done you know
what happened son
now uh as of 40 4 55 today yes what
happened at 4 55 today your key card
would not work in this building
okay you've been in revoked access and
and listen we don't have any plan on who
to put inside your place but we'll find
somebody in this building
but we need somebody to play video games
because obviously what has happened to
the PlayStation brand is that guy that
was in charge didn't play video your
feelings control again but got rid of
Jim
well you know we'll be taking over and
effectively Monday we're going to kill
all games of services we won't have any
games coming out we will rely on Indies
we will take it back
cancel the PlayStation uh VR that's uh
says pool of money being thrown in the
bushes uh that's not happening and the
portal the portal is done we're gonna
cancel that
order arrival we're at a gym there's
people that's already pre-ordered the
portal that's nice we're gonna we're
gonna keep their money because we know
that they like the patreon stuff so we
don't give any refunds but we do like
the fact that you did pre-order but it
won't you you you're gonna get it like
the initial people are gonna get the
ones they've already made no and then
there's just never gonna be any updates
on it's like well you bought it you got
it
he's trying to keep it together on the
side of balance and reason
um solve your thoughts Jim Ryan uh no
longer the uh head of PlayStation and
and your thoughts on just all of this
stuff that's going on
at the view because I'd be coughing too
much
uh
it's it's funny that y'all you know yes
you I knew y'all were gonna take them
out
we do we do but at the end of the day I
think y'all were the first ones to say
and y'all were wrong you were saying
that
this is the path that had to be walked
talk to
you had to be walked somebody had to do
it because otherwise the alternative was
don't pivot correct don't react to What
Microsoft's doing and be even worse off
right and really really be in the bind
and maybe
yeah you're pleasing the PlayStation
faithful right you're giving them
exactly what they wanted games not
coming to PC true exclusives
they like that
and you're really really when you look
at the landscape look at what
Microsoft's doing not trying to do any
more doing
and that's a problem
So You Needed Somebody
in that position
who was going to go in cold cold not
care handle the business aspect of it
take those shots because the shots were
coming and then in his attempt try to be
no no shots was that Phil Dominus Maxim
is it really expensive most of it was
coming from there it was coming from
field right so I think Phil hits and
they were and they were also it was also
coming from the PlayStation faithful
right the ones that were like what is
going on here what is all this stuff
that's happening double agents and so
you needed somebody there that was not
gonna care about all of that stuff
playing games and was going to try to
put them in a position to compete where
they could they were never able they
were never going to be able to compete
with Microsoft monetarily right so the
idea money funny compared to Microsoft
everybody's money funny so you know the
idea that you know him it was he was
never going to block the ABK deal he was
out there to be no
I I truly believe Jim thought he could
block that deal you thought he went
rogue that he went wrong I think he
pushed the higher ups to believe he
blocked that
right okay if you say you say that right
you say that but Jim's A smart business
man right if you're a smart businessman
and you read your aim is to really
really do everything you can to block
that deal he said that a little there is
no way no no I'm saying it but if your
aim is really really like I'm going to
block this deal now I don't want no he
said I don't want you to do I want to
block this deal
in your heart of hearts if you really
believe that a you work hand in hand
with the FTC and make sure and you we
don't know all right
stuff
every week we heard this man in a
different country trying to talk to him
about that uh
at the same time if you go there and you
drop these bombs you snitch right right
yeah yeah if you don't caress them and
and show them how to argue this in a way
that makes sense
what good are you what a good assistant
doing basically you snitched to people
who then took the argument
and then came to court with the
stupidest reasons possible why this
shouldn't happen it should never have
been argued in the way that it was
argued and maybe we would have seen a
different a different outcome right yeah
but so we gotta admit we have to admit
we hindsides 2020 but remember the whole
I hate to call it because the the fly
the dance moves flying right it started
because we heard he was going to
Brussels or whatever it was right then
we gotta admit at the time
everything that The Regulators were
saying would see like it was
regurgitated from Jim's boss
and and we have to admit
FTC and the CMA block this thing look
dead in the water it looked completely
like everything was on his side and if
it and let's be honest only King was out
there hold the lock that's not hold the
line
I was on some I think this is over okay
whatever Direction leads to this beat
over I'm gonna go that direction hold
the line was King's moment because it
looked almost impossible you have an
Xbox to turn this thing off like like
prominent people
experts saying there's no way the truck
tweeting right behind them saying shut
up you don't know what you're talking
about right and and the only slither of
hope that happened because that was
right around the time when Phil had to
go to the game awards after the block
and the joint and the only thing that
was always got to say well let's see
what happened with the EU but the
percentages are so slim and so we gotta
say that in in attic's defense
did he had the the boot on the neck and
this thing looked like a done deal
before this magical turnaround happened
it's like he he was choking the life out
of the deal and right before they
inspired he just let go he thought he
was done he thought it was over started
walking back with his hands in the air
it's over and then you see you see that
Xbox logo just get up this is more like
uh Julio Cesar Chavez magic Taylor yeah
get beat for whole yes yeah
we were telling y'all hey man calm down
stop you know hold the line you're an
idiot for holding line then now you had
to go back
okay so if you didn't learn from that
right came right back to it and I told
you Jim was gone in the next fiscal
period you said that he's leaving win
do you think that they're making him uh
if he is being forced out that they want
to do it now because they want those
investors
I don't believe it listen I will concede
the point that he yes all right he was
old enough
I don't think this causes him to be
pushed at all
realistic hold up real quick
we're not we're not about the ABK deal
we're talking about Studios being shut
down we're talking about the lack of
their first party because let's be real
screen it's been keeping the PlayStation
5 afloat okay
let me ask you what what is Studio Japan
done of lately oh man yo it's down it's
it's it doesn't exist it does it right
what what before it got shut down what
what what thing of note what are they
doing at that time even though
even though they weren't delivering they
still had other things that you've done
for me lately what have you done for me
lately at that time PlayStation had
stuff for them all I'm saying is this
business they were tough business
decisions that had to be made
the business guy there to do that right
okay here's the thing so the reason I'm
pushing back on this let them talk let
them talk we got to let them talk
yeah we're so mad we're Saul but he's
trying to realize
the man
within their Silo he still managed to
launch a console in the middle of covet
facts that had no stock
um
and then when you had the opportunity to
have people who would buy your console
didn't have they didn't have the council
to buy they didn't go over to the other
side they waited and they bought your
console MPD once the stock was up it's
crazy
and what did he do he introduced what
they needed what they needed to even
remotely try to compare with what
Microsoft is doing
and it's still right so he's gonna walk
out before he knows if that's if that's
successful hey okay whatever yeah don't
know what listen if you have an
opportunity to write your own exit
ticket hey
do you want to take that smoke or do you
want to walk off into the sunset with
the w right I left it in the good enough
place to you see this is another thing
that gets me about y'all
all these metrics
you cannot compare what Microsoft does
to them anymore there's no metric like
right but you can't but but you are
every single moment you're saying that
I'm telling you what is you talking
about they sold so many into the code
and these guys got them all doesn't
matter who got them it doesn't matter
who got them
are they sitting on the store so no not
in customer here
to some people it doesn't matter who it
doesn't matter if they bought them and
then they dumped them in the river five
minutes later it don't matter it was